another Fox News Alert now onto Capitol
Hill where the nation's top expert on
infectious diseases will testify this
morning on safely reopening the nation's
economy dr. Anthony Fauci will testify
remotely before the Senate Health
Committee along with three other key
members of the White House coronavirus
task force and according to early
reports
ouchy plans to issue a warning that
reopening too quickly could be dangerous
the Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
urging pouchy not to hold back this will
be one of the first opportunities for
dr. Fauci to tell the American people
the unvarnished truth without the
president lurking over his shoulder
doctor foul Qi let it rip Bret Baier
Dana Perino and our top doctors will
join us shortly on all that but first
our congressional correspondent Chad
program kicks off our coverage this
morning good morning Chad good morning
at well this is the first big hearing on
coronavirus remember the House of
Representatives wanted Anthony Fauci
last week and the White House would not
let him testify it this hearing is going
to focus on reopening the economy
bringing people back to work and back to
school but there are a lot of questions
as to whether or not different states
are jumping the gun and here is
something that foul she is going to
testify to this morning quote this will
not only result in needless suffering
and death but would actually set us back
in our quest to return to normal here is
the Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
until now we've mostly heard from the
members of the coronavirus task force
through the distorted lens of the White
House Conference where the president
often prevents them from answering fully
interrupts their response or even
contradicts their fact-based advice this
hearing will look different than most of
the witnesses will testify remotely
Falchi and others had potential exposure
to corona virus at the White House an
aide to Senator Mitty Chairman Lamar
Alexander contracted corona virus so
he's in self-isolation for two weeks the
top Democrat on the panel Washington
senator patty Murray has been working
from home after the big nursing home
outbreak in her state last week
Alexander said lawmakers flying back and
forth to Washington could create a quote
highly a fish
virus spreading machine the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell is
focused on another hearing today dealing
with lawsuits and coronavirus liability
this would be just about the worst time
in living memory to let trial lawyers
lie on their pockets at the expense of
the rest of our country the Senate's
going to play a strong role in ensuring
that does not happen now we're going to
watch to see if Falchi differs from the
president and other administration
officials in any of the testimony today
and also here's something to look for we
talked about how this hearing is going
to look different than most hearings
with most of the Senators being a
beaming and remotely will the visuals
outweigh the testimony as they talk
about the steps needed to be taken to
reopen the United States all right
important information will be all over
at 10:00 program thank you